you want to take the rest unfortunately
that's not how this works
it has to be him so how about you do
yourself a favor get out of my ring and
watch along with everybody else
doesn't trying to do what he believes to
be the right thing we're only the
halfway point yeah I think it's been
five I yeah
Bryce Rensburg the referee advisability
that he has five five more big shots to
take
[Applause]
[Applause]
can we witness to want a lot I don't
agree with this anything like those
everything in arresting hearing system
so emotional
and infancy bestowed even though he's
not rode the outside
he's got more lashes coming in close
you can hand to me to jail
[Applause]
is it really worth it I mean it wouldn't
be from new pal I hit him up all over
goodness fat from my ass
this is dead dead serious tears in his
eyes
gritting his teeth trying to dig deep
and find some reserve and fortitude
Manning up again and again I gotta ask
being coached up by the elite attending
took just three more to go
[Applause]
got ulama city hate to use the word
agent it's a very bad word I just hate
to see this
seniors stayed in I guess on all fours
[Applause]
wealth laceration we've gotten it in
being like an animal save distaste
more
[Applause]
and then one more
[Applause]
mr. Mahan
what part of deal was it you heard
Dustin say he could hear him very
clearly it's not part of the deal
Oh
giving me to my lashes
he's bleeding down believe that's a
massive 275 pound man with everything he
had he wound up and stepped into it nope
our medical staff is standing by and
[Applause]
maybe it maybe it maybe it
I'm sayin said I guess you're not
getting the man
Randy Billy's wife
[Applause]
[Music]